Oh what to do Ballas
welcome to real mature it's a show that
we make about things you do when you
grow up one of the things you do when
you grow up is you become more cool with
yourself so today we have three
different videos about different people
and how they became cool with themselves
the first one is about our friend Gabby
right here hello how was your walk I'm
like sweating yeah you look incredibly
sweaty please tell me we got it this
time
I think so okay cool get the [ __ ] off
here
first video is a video that Gaby made
with Colin yeah I've been in a lot of
videos on BuzzFeed and all over the
internet and I've been called a lot of
mean things because I seem to be kind of
polarizing but one word comes up all the
time and that is [ __ ] so I wanted to do
an investigation into what that word
means and if I am one let's go do you
guys ever get called a [ __ ] no I don't
think I've ever been called a [ __ ] yeah
it's a real thing that they only seem to
call loud women
I've only been called a [ __ ] in like a
positive way yeah it's [ __ ] out wait
could you elaborate on that what do you
mean by that you know like my college
slaying Colin Flynn yeah what yeah what
a [ __ ] it's grass it is gross
so what's the first thing that you guys
did first thing that we did is we took
it to the streets what makes somebody a
[ __ ] it's the quantity I think that
makes personalizes the quantity five
people in one night you know every day
all day seven days a week
sexy clothes and by sexy clothes I mean
just strings somebody that sleeps with a
lot of people well in my opinion Isleta
someone who does not practice
self-control self-restraint if you feel
like that you've devalued yourself and I
would think that that [ __ ] M is what
how would I know no I would say not no
no you notice like well how do you know
that you don't know me that's true but I
mean maybe I don't know you don't seem
like a slight I don't seem like a [ __ ]
internet now you know
it's interesting that no one seemed to
have liked this same definition of what
it was but they all kind of agree this
fat yeah
and when pushed a little bit the
definition falls apart No so what do you
guys do next we asked some lovely people
to come in and told them to draw what
they think a [ __ ] looks like alright
let's watch that can you draw a [ __ ]
please oh okay I'm a terrible drawer a
[ __ ]
you guys are gonna hate the pants why
don't you hold it up in point - what's
what - show us well I have a girl with
her legs open big boobs and if I had
more time and artistic ability maybe I
would draw like a dick in her hand her
mouths opened in your mouths open
waiting for a day - its Pigpen from the
peanuts cartoon because I heard that the
word [ __ ] used to mean just like dirty a
[ __ ] doesn't exist in my mind because I
would never call anybody a [ __ ] years of
television media I'm assuming this is
what a hooker looks like I just figured
the easiest way to convey [ __ ] is a
woman that says yes to all men cuz she's
got her legs wide open just a little a
little bit of a [ __ ] why did you draw a
woman because you know I've like never
seen on TV and movies like a male
streetwalker
okay so what do we learn from the
drawing well mostly we learn that
everybody's opinions on what a [ __ ]
looks like is different and I was still
pretty confused I mean it's a big word
it's a it's full of history it's full of
weight it's it's a lot yeah and I don't
think that anybody really knew what they
were drawing all right so we're gonna
get more into Gabby's investigation in a
second but we have another video that
was made by the beautiful Shane so I'm
gonna run up and get him and bring her
back here and he's gonna tell us about
his video
hey beautiful Shane going hanky
I remember that thing I told you we'd
have to do yeah yeah that's happening
right now oh great you ready to go to
your room chair yeah all right you first
after you Shane oh my show
snatcher [ __ ] damn it you're back uh so
what up Shane uh not much
you know that's a bit Gabi have you met
beautiful Shane before with yeah we have
but never at this eyeline cuz I'm on an
Apple box now so I can see into all your
faces you're ruining dealers sorry sorry
okay so tell us what your burger uh it's
a video about rejection I have always
been kind of curious about it but about
the way people process it and this video
is about rejection therapy which is
where people dive right in the goal is
to get rejected every day in some way or
another so people were given prompts of
ways that they would get rejected
correct it's a social game what is the
example of a front person one of them is
asking to trade parking spots with
someone and what happens if somebody
says yes then you find out that the
world is a little more malleable than
you thought the goal though is to get
rejected so you've failed okay so is the
goal to like cry at the end of the day
no the goal at the end of the day is to
feel like you put yourself out there and
you've been rejected by someone and
you're still alive and you know take
what you will from that alright let's
check it out yeah Hey
rejection is a big part of life and it's
the worst it's pretty easy to avoid
though if you just don't put yourself
out there hey man no but is there any
value in it is rejection good for
something these were the questions that
JA Jiang was asking himself when he
started 100 days of rejection therapy
I feel growing up I was afraid to step
out and do things I was afraid to get
rejected by my family and friends and to
fail so I did this thing called a
hundred days of rejection based on a
game called rejection therapy where
basically you go out every day and look
for rejection so I said I'm going to do
this for 100 days I'll start a video
blog about it after the first time I
started basically I went and how to
found a stranger and as they can about
$100 from you excuse me do you think I'm
for $100 from you no all right all right
that was one of the most awkward and
scary moment I feel almost in my life so
the next day I said I'm not gonna run no
matter what happened
Brooke it's really good to get a
further afield after the initial
rejection I didn't run I stay engaged
and that made me feel much more powerful
much more confident that life and death
feeding was gone all right I got a no so
day two was a success so from there all
I said my job is putting myself out
there
ask ask for things and see what happens
can I deliver your next pizza for you
maybe a life management for you can you
see me like a German Shepherd I found
out that rejection says much more about
the other person than me can I take a
quick nap here really the fear of
rejection is very sneaky is the force
that at the back of your mind that
controls a lot of decision you're making
hi how are you good to me I'm just
getting the sliced pineapple
so slice of pineapple rideable so
sometimes people do say no it's still
alright it's a little awkward I asked
for a discount at Starbucks and is there
any discount I could get the lady just
like thought I was crazy oh you guys
don't okay that's okay
the most surprising thing to me was just
how nice it was to just talk to people a
lot of times um I think if you preface
like I know this is super weird but I
come hear it all the time and I really
really like these pen sometimes if you
do something weird and go out of your
way it opens up this like human
connection that I forget is there can i
buy these pens is there a way I can the
FedEx guy just seems like the guy who's
working there but you ask him a little
question like something's kind of weird
and we really had this bond where he was
like yeah just just take the pen
okay and the guy behind me at Starbucks
I never would think to talk to anyone
like that I'm always on my phone you
know what you I got your coffee today
your plate lemon fighting Miko yeah is
that okay with you it's the worst
absolute worst thing that could have
happened was he was like no and he found
it kind of weird but instead I had this
like nice moment with his stranger and
as I was leaving her but just both
smiling not really made my day and I
didn't think it was gonna happen like
that I feel like the thing I learned
most from this experience was just that
you know putting yourself out there it's
kind of like fun and it comes with
rewards sometimes you people say no but
like no isn't a big deal rejection is a
good and normal part of life and if
anything it just clarifies who you are
so don't be afraid to go out there and
try something new
you might hear no but you might get a
big old yes so do it good lesson right
yeah yeah if you're okay with yourself
then you don't make it the rejection
personal no and maybe there's not as
much to be afraid out in the world well
in that case you should get the heck out
of your shame okay cool oh you're
addicted chained I get it take that
pretty well
okay so the next thing you guys did is
you went in found an expert to explain
the word [ __ ] yeah I went and talked to
Emily Linden who's the founder of the
unslung project which is a project
that's anti bullying and anti
slut-shaming awesome yeah check it out
what is slut-shaming i define it as
implying that a girl or a woman should
feel guilty or inferior for real or
perceived sexual behavior what have you
seen in your research has been reasons
that women have been called [ __ ] the
better question is what are some reasons
that a woman would not be called a [ __ ]
I mean really it's anything literally
any woman at any time can be deemed a
[ __ ]
it's in the eye of the beholder so
you're a [ __ ] if someone else thinks
you're is what yeah at any point in time
or someone like spreads a rumor about
you it you can't prevent anyone from
calling you a [ __ ] by how you dress or
how you act or where you are youing out
with does matter so there's nothing I
can do I wouldn't ask people on the
street right and they had all kinds of
different answers from girls who go to
the club too much than also the typical
you know girl who has a lot of sex but
he couldn't really quantify what a lot
is yeah how much sex how much is too
much so there were not a lot of real
answers and then when I would ask them
Oh am i a [ __ ] without knowing me at all
they would say no no of course not
my takeaway is like is it such a bad
thing yeah or even that it's not a thing
I mean that [ __ ] can't be defined really
because it's whatever anyone wants to
use to keep a woman in a place that they
think she belongs in so when you're
saying that people call you a [ __ ] in
the comments it might be because the way
that you come across in your videos or
the way that you talk or the way that
you look is something that makes that
comment or feel like they want to put
you back in a place you know where you
belong I guess so I guess one way that
you could personally avoid it is to stop
speaking is to stop making videos yeah
yeah and you're very loud please
what it do everybody we're back okay I
don't know what we're doing Henry's
supposed to be hosting but I guess he's
in a meeting so the crew call me I'm
here to host interim halfway through the
video what did we just watch we watched
an interview with Emily linden from the
unsplit project so as you can see there
are a lot of ways in which [ __ ] is used
to demean women clearly but you maybe
don't come up here pretending like you
can host videos you don't know what
they're about Hey look I'm just doing
what people told me to do
so the next video I actually made and
admittedly it's actually a little bit
weird but it fits in this realm of being
cool with yourself it's a theater
project called living canvas you'd
probably be into it it's a bunch of
people get naked and projection
projections are sort of shot on them I'd
probably be injured yeah I mean at least
watching it you'd be all about cultural
exploration and opening oneself up to
June you want a shovel for this entire
just host the video yeah let's just
watch the day what really started to
affect me was the first show that I did
the second night a woman came up to me
and said I saw your show last night and
I went home took off my clothes stood in
front of a mirror and felt better about
myself when that happened then I knew
that I had to keep doing this because it
was not only having an effect on the
people in the show but on audiences
feeling better about themselves and
that's just too important to pass up
I'm Jake Kaczynski I'm 24 years old I'm
Dominic Jackson I'm 22 we're going to be
naked um they're going to be projecting
images and textures onto our naked
bodies while we tell a theatrical story
living canvas is essentially an art form
that uses the amazing expressive
capabilities of the human body combined
with imagery to to make a change in
people whether it's the performers or
the audience and that to me is very
exciting being here with the way that my
body is and not being afraid to just
show that I think is really important I
mean I feel like it will instill a sense
of acceptance and just what I've gone
through and what I've taken my body
through this far we really strove for it
was body positivity um accepting our
flaws for what they are and we just
tried in various ways through movement
exploration as we said earlier to
encompass that sort of emotion in what
we were bringing to the stage and in the
end we brought it together with this
really nice piece with colors that match
their personalities and little voiceover
statements about us accepting who we are
I am scarred and whole I am assertive
and strong I am just right I am ripped
with creativity
nature's passion is my mirror I've
earned my marks these are my tiger
stripes I've embraced my unwashed masses
I was built to be me just being part of
that group and seeing people be that
comfortable and vulnerable with each
other wasn't like it was really
enlightening and refreshing and it made
me feel a lot more comfortable Who I am
it's an equalizer yeah it's the great
equalizer you realize that everyone's
equal and everyone has to say hang-ups
and it's it's nice to recognize that in
other people so that video was obviously
perfect I made it it was perfect it was
great and it was just a classic what it
do so
you're gone so I started hosting the
show my video happened already okay what
are we right here guys please be friends
I don't know I don't know where we are
to be honest I was really thrown into
this by these guys do you wanna Tate do
you want to take over yeah
sound a little confused what the [ __ ]
just happened
they made Keith post I just want to say
I don't support Keith as host I fully
support Henry I'm sorry that's not what
you said ten minutes ago Gabby we love
Keith he's a valued member of the IRL
team and he made an awesome video it's
fine
let's talk about your video yeah uh so
what's the last part of your [ __ ]
journey so we got a lot of opinions
about what it means to be a [ __ ] but we
needed to go to the source hi honey
hello this is my mom right this is mom
what is your opinion on how I love you
so do I think you're a [ __ ] I wouldn't
use that word I'm proud I guess your
ability to have so much confidence and
the fact that you say whatever you want
to say I don't know many women who could
do that but sometimes it's just a little
too much yes bring it out so yes do it
and so sometimes like that sometimes I
hear your grandmother on my shoulder you
know like oh my god no I don't think
you're a [ __ ] I think you're a light for
everybody else who is free sexually
you've opened my eyes to look at women
differently and less judgmental
oh you're welcome you [ __ ] mom I mean I
guess like the question is do you feel
like you understand what a [ __ ] means
and whether it's you like you are a [ __ ]
ah
my takeaway is so what if I am doesn't
matter I'm me I'm cool with me I'm happy
and it's nobody's business
is Ellie your takeaway of the video is
calm you know the word [ __ ] doesn't
really mean anything and if you want to
be a [ __ ] go for it if you don't hey
don't worry about it
and if I am one oh well then it's not a
bad thing alright [ __ ] it then be who
you are
uh and with that we start off what it do
say what I do I'm
gonna say come on say what girl you
almost got me to say everything I
wouldn't say just say why would you say
what what did do [ __ ] alright that's it
thank you for watching real mature
this episode real mature was produced by
the BuzzFeed IRL they're the literal
best special thanks to be real credit
for some of the kids
Gabi Josh and Anna little cams see you
next time
you
you